hey guys it is Monday my name is Jeff
and you're watching games but knees
first that Blizzard has commented on
overwatch is mixed heroes I hate to dash
your hopes straight away but it doesn't
sound like a new hero is going to be
doomed first sorry Terry Crews game
director Jeff Kaplan address the rumors
on the game's official forums saying 24
is not who you think it is obviously
that doesn't mean doom fest won't be
coming to the hero shooter just that the
24th over what hero maybe someone
different the upcoming hero will be the
third added to the game post launch the
first to being haka sombra and sniper
Anna according to Kaplan blizzard have
multiple new heroes being worked on
right now plus numerous events and event
related content next up Nintendo has
revealed a bunch of file sizes for
switch games that can be downloaded
digitally to your internal hardware so
let's start registering them on their
Nintendo's Japanese website release the
info today and I have bad news for those
of you who are planning to pick up
Dragon Quest heroes 1 & 2 weighing in at
the largest file size the game stacks up
to 32 gigabytes the same size as
switches internal memory so you will
need to grab yourself a microSD card of
32 gigabytes or more to run that one as
for some of the other upcoming switch
games breath of the wild is 13.4
gigabyte mario kart 8 deluxe is 8
gigabytes employer / 0 tatras is 1.09
gigabytes we've now tetris tetris onto
your switch hard drive so i think we can
move on this which still supports micro
SDXC cards of up to 2 terabytes of space
if space becomes a real issue for you
you can check out the rest of the
released file sizes for switch games in
our story on gamespot finally with us to
have revealed they've got quite a few
projects in the works director todd
howard told IGN bethesda have seven
projects in various stages of
development for for VR and Skyrim for
nintendo switch have already been
announced leaving five to be revealed in
a recent interview with glick cyl Howard
said we're bigger now and we do want to
be putting out more stuff we have two
larger projects that are more
classically the scale of what we
do but even bigger I can't talk a lot
about them but I can say that they're
bigger than anything we've ever done
they're a bit different but definitely
in the wheelhouse that people are used
to from us he also revealed the Bethesda
is working on a new mobile game as a
follow-up to fallout shelter which will
be a different style game that is unique
in the space fingers crossed some of
these projects will be revealed at
Bethesda t3 conference on sunday june 11
this year that is everything I've got
for you today do subscribe to get
yourself more daily gaming news head to
gamespot for our horizon review and I
will see you tomorrow